This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
this. program is for educational
purposes only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We're honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Hello. Hello everybody. Welcome back, my
friends, to Daily with Doc and Becca. My
name is Becca Dukes, and this program is
being brought to you by
dailywithdoc.com.
Now, today's going to be a little bit
different as we are going to be talking
not just about health, but we're talking
about families and the foundations for
healthier life. So, we're going to be
talking also about families that have
chosen to incorporate Young Jeevity into
being proactive when it comes to our
kids. So, if you are a mom, a dad, a
grandparent, a caregiver, an auntie, an
uncle, great grandparent, this program
is for you. as we are making conscious
decisions to build wellness from the
inside out, starting with our children.
And it's not just starting with our
children. We're going to be showing you
some kids that have been raised on the
Young Jevity products and how they are
developing and how the parents feel
that. Um, and sometimes the kids don't
notice the difference, but we as parents
absolutely do. So, this is not about
perfection. And it's not about um you
know making sure that our kids are like
perfect in every way because they're
perfect in our own eyes, right? No
matter what. But this is about intention
folks as it's about stewarding our
children in health teaching them about
food how nutriers
and giving their bodies the building
blocks that they need during those
critical growing years and beyond. So
stay tuned with us as we're going to be
hearing about some families and some
stories and their insights and
encouragement for other parents when it
comes to raising healthy kids. So, if
you are here live with us and somebody
invited you, make sure that you get back
with them as they took the time and
cared enough about you to share this
program to encourage you. Because folks,
you know, there's a lot of things that
happen to us as we're growing
and there's a lot of things that we've
been told are genetic or, hey, you just
can't avoid it. Well, Dr. Joel Wallik,
one of the founders of the young com
longevity company, my mentor, somebody
that I was honored to spend two years
um as his apprentice, his his what would
you call it? Um personal assistant and
helped in his publishing company
is one of the founding fathers of a
science called epigenetics.
Now, epigenetics has proven that theory
of
genetic disease transmission to be
incorrect.
So folks,
we're looking at one U-turns for
ourselves. most importantly today, how
we can support our children so they
don't have to deal with some of the
things that we may have dealt with when
it came to how the body responds without
the proper nutrition. So today the
we've got uh several parents, some of my
friends that I just absolutely love and
adore on with us whose kids have been
thriving
when using the Youngevity products in
their food. Uh what would you call it?
Jill,
I would like you to come on with me
since you're traveling. You got a great
connection right now. Let's just get you
in here because you're traveling to go
see one of your kiddos.
>> Yes, I am.
>> Your son?
>> I am.
>> So, so tell us about Ian.
>> Um I have a one son. His name's Ian. And
Ian is 21 years old. We're traveling
right now to uh watch a track meet um
that he has. Um he runs track for
Flaggler College. and um we're really
excited to go, you know, spend some time
with him. Uh Ian started uh on the
products when he was 10 years old. Um I
personally found longevity in 2014. I
kind of found it by accident and I had
some pretty serious health challenges
that I was living with for 20 years. So
when I found it, I pretty much did what
Dr. while told me to do right aways and
right aways everything started changing
in my body. So um I I knew that
everything was different at 3 weeks but
at 6 weeks my family my son and my
husband started taking nutrition too
because we knew it wasn't just hocus
pocus it was uh you know it it it was
making um all the difference for me. So
that's when my son started. It was about
six weeks after I did. And I'll tell you
that my son was a little bit premature.
I had
>> Wait, you got you got muted. Let's go
ahead and get you back unmuted.
>> Sorry, I'm holding the phone because
we're in the car.
>> Yeah. So, he was premature. We caught
that.
>> Yeah. I was induced because I had
serious health challenges and so as soon
as they thought his lungs were developed
they induced me. Um and his lungs were
actually a little bit premature. Uh they
were a little wrong and so he ended up
with uh baby asthma and with seasonal
inter intermittent allergies which most
of the time was not awful.
it when he got sick and he needed an you
know an inhaler um he he just his lung
issues showed at that point in time. So
he was on medication from a wee baby. He
took previsit he took singular uh he had
reflux and he also um had uh like I said
seasonal intermittent allergies and baby
asthma. And so he lived that way till he
was 10 years old. he took um took those
things and uh pretty much we could tell
as soon as we started him on nutrition
that things were changing in him too. So
uh it was just a couple months till he
was able to get off of those products
that he had been on till he was 10 years
old. I mean those medications. So here's
an early shot of him about the time he
probably started. That's showing uh the
kids sprinkles which is a kids uh
multivitamin. It's a little uh it's kind
of like a pixie stick. You pour it on
your tongue and it has vitamins uh in it
and it tastes good. My son really
enjoyed that. That was the one of the
first products he started. And then
that's Cherry Men's. That's my other
kid. That's my husband Rob. Um and
Cherry Men's is like a healthy shot. And
you can get that in a couple different
flavors, but that's what my son did at
that point. He did those two products.
That's what he started with and he just
did the healthy shot. And then here he
is drinking Beyond Tangy Tangerine which
is uh you know one of our uh top
products in the company uh is what
changed my health. Um and uh
so so
he also took something called uh bone
builder which had calcium, magnesium,
vitamin uh D and it also has a little
bit of glucosamine in it and um
essential fatty acids. and the essential
fatty acids were one of the things that
really helped him with his lungs um with
uh him being able to get uh over that.
Um and the last time that we went to the
doctor um they did say he no longer had
any of those issues. He no longer had
the the asthma or the seasonal
intermittent allergies. So um we're
we're real thrilled with that. Here he
is a little bit older. This is my son's
favorite product. He loves uh rebound in
a can. So many kids are drinking those
energy drinks that they pick up here,
there, and everywhere. And they have
awful things in them. And our Rebound in
a can um is just packed with vitamins
and minerals and uh none of that bad
stuff.
It has great flavor. It has a little bit
of fizz and um it's to this day my son's
favorite product. But here he's showing
it. Um I did I think there it is. Yeah,
he just got it for Christmas because he
still really uh enjoys it as well. Um
and the cans, they fly out of the house.
Um my son's friends all love them. Uh he
lives in a house with uh soccer athletes
and um they would fly out of the
refrigerator there, too. Um so they're
very hard to keep in stock. Um here is a
picture of my son. Uh first of all, I'll
just mention one of my son's other
favorite products is called Electrofuel.
It's an energy drink um that has zero
calories, zero carbs, so it's pretty
much good for anyone. Has a raspberry
flavor. And um this is my son. He also
played soccer. Um my son is a state
soccer champion. And we're very proud of
the fact that not only is he a champion,
did his team win, but my son actually
kicked in uh the winning goal. Uh and
part of the little story there is that
uh my son he really you could see the
difference in him on the athletic field
from his teammates. Especially on the
soccer field you could really see it
because um at soccer they don't often
take you out if you're good. You're
playing uh with very few breaks. And a
lot of his teammates we would watch them
cramping up. We'd watch them falling
down with leg cramps, with uh issues
that they would have to be taken off the
field or some of them ended up with
injuries that completely sidelined them.
Uh and my son did not experience any of
that. Um because he w had the nutrition
on board. Um it made the biggest
difference for him. And uh in this state
championship game uh what they did is
they pulled we were outmatched and the
other team was actually better but they
pulled all of the offensive players and
put them on defense with the exception
of my son. My son was the only person uh
on offense and he just ran around like
the Energizer buddy waiting for the
opportunity uh to um have something uh
that he could take up the field and put
into the net and he did. So, um, we're
just real proud of that. And like I
said, we could always see the difference
in his level of energy and, uh, and, you
know, just in the vitality that he had
even at that young age compared to his
friends and the other athletes.
>> How about this picture?
>> Yeah. Well, that's my son that he's he's
making those muscles in that other
picture, too, I think. I'm pretty sure.
or maybe that was my husband making the
muscles. Uh but this is his track
picture from from this year. Uh this is
him now at 21. Uh healthy and strong and
none of those lung problems, you know,
that he experienced for the first 10
years. He doesn't have them anymore. Um
he he, you know, he's just normal and
healthy. Well, he's better than normal
because uh you don't know what you don't
know. And um unfortunately, there's just
so many people out there that don't know
the difference. Uh, but I feel great
that um, we're giving my son what he
needs for his body to fuel him and to
keep him healthy. Um, another thing that
we always give him is selenium. Um,
really, really important. We hear so
many things happening to athletes on the
athletic field and selenium is a super
important uh, nutrient to have on board
as well and Ian has always taken taken
that um, since we first started.
Okay,
>> fantastic. Awesome. So,
folks, are you listening?
If you got kiddos with lung issues,
they're not going to have them forever
as long as their bodies are being
supported with the right nutrition. Now,
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician.
It's not meant to treat, diagnose, or
cure any disease. But folks, when you
give the body what it needs, the body
itself can do some amazing things. It
doesn't matter what age you're at. So,
thank you, Jill.
>> I have one other product. I have it. I
have one other favorite product. I
should have mentioned it because it's a
good one for kids, right, of all ages.
Is my son also loves root beer belly
>> and that is also like a pixie stick sort
of thing. You just pour open it up and
pour it directly on your tongue. It
actually tastes like root beer. Tastes
great. But it's a probiotic. It has five
different strands. It has five billion
probiotic in it. And what it does is it
not only repairs your digestive system,
but it helps you when you have a belly
ache. And so, uh, he loves that. And he,
um, we used to keep it in the candy dish
when he was little because he knew if he
had a belly ache, he could go for it.
But we learned when he was a teenager,
we couldn't because all his friends
wanted it too because they had belly
aches. So,
>> well, just to get the taste, I had a
belly ache whether I got one or not.
They still
>> actually I really think a lot of them
did. I really think a lot of them had
digestive issues and so Ian was trying
to be kind and we'd go through a box
like instantly and I'd be like, "Look,
everybody's welcome to try it, but at
some point, you know, we need to talk
with our parents about
>> getting the solution on a more permanent
basis." So, anyway, thank you. I really
appreciate the opportunity um to tell
people about our experience with it and
it longevity definitely changed my
health, my life, and my family's health
as well.
>> Well, thank you so much, Jill, for
coming on with us. I know you're on the
road now from Pennsylvania to Florida to
go to one of Ian's track meets. So,
that's absolutely fantastic that we were
able to catch you in a spot where you
had great connection and service. Thank
you. Thank you. Well, folks, you know,
>> has a question for Jill.
>> Oh, AJ, question.
>> Hi, AJ.
>> Hey, Jill. Thanks for coming on. Jill,
given that your son plays soccer,
I'm gonna throw a a dart and say that
he's a distance runner.
>> Oh, no. The opposite. He's a sprinter.
My son's gift is that he's he is he's
fast. My son's fast on the soccer field.
He's fast uh on the track. He's been
fast in every sport that he has. It
doesn't matter what it is, he's fast and
he has that endurance. And like I said,
they all the parents all comment on how
my son has the endurance that they don't
see from other people that he's the he's
the Energizer Bunny. So, yeah. No, it
his gift is that he's fast and that's
how that's what worked for him on the
soccer field is he could get he could
get places other people couldn't get
because he was really fast.
And they then they don't ask you what
he's doing. Like they don't say, "Wow,
your son's really fast. Can we do some
of that stuff, too?" Like,
>> "Yes, of course. Of course they do. We
we we do have plenty of opportunities to
talk to people uh about adding nutrition
as well." And uh my husband definitely
he's a good giver. He likes to uh hand
out packets of rebound uh to those kids
that we do see suffering, the ones that
we see falling down with the leg cramps.
Um my husband is always all over that.
Handing them the packets of rebound and
handing them
>> um the uh the electro fuel as well.
>> That's awesome. Any other questions, AJ?
>> Oh, got a thumbs up.
>> Awesome. Thank you. Thank you. Now,
because I have somebody that's just like
itching to get out of here and I'm like
super excited that he will even come on
screen with me is I have my youngest who
just this morning said, "Can I have a
kid sprinkles because they still taste
good to him at 14?" Um,
what's the thing that you notice most or
have noticed? So, or what are you
taking?
>> Okay. So, he
>> you didn't tell him he had to talk.
You didn't tell him he'd be forced to
speak.
>> So, he he takes the on the-go pack. So,
it's easier for him as he's traveling
back and forth between myself and his
father. Um, and he also takes the
D-Stress on the on the-go pack. It has
four of the Beyond Tangy Tangerine
tablets, one of the mineral caps, one of
the ultimate cow, and then an EFA. Plus,
he takes extra EFAs and the D-stress.
So, as a young man that has had some
um
challenges with getting in front of
people,
I think the d-stress does help him some.
And AJ has some questions. AJ
>> Alex, how tall are you?
>> Last time I checked, 5 foot 11 and a
half.
>> Are you taller than me?
If I remember correctly, maybe m Don't
don't you tell people you're taller than
me, man. That's that's not fair. This is
national television. I'm just No, but
Alex is an amazing young man and I'm
glad that you came on with us and uh you
know, between adding nutrition and
exercise,
Alex is just he's gonna take it by
storm. You're going to take the world by
storm. People need to watch out for this
kid. He's a good kid. Good man. Good
young man. That's all I got to say. Stop
being shy.
>> So So Alex is my brainiac child. He is
very sharp. He He just loves science. Um
and
anything you put in front of him, he
like is a a sponge. And I love the fact
that he's wanting to get into culinary
arts which we can incorporate the
nutrition in there as well. Now one of
the biggest things with him because I
think he's my fastest growing child
where the others experienced and I
myself I remember my grandmother rubbing
my legs because I was having growing
pains so bad in my legs. He has not had
any growing pains.
And I think that's absolutely fantastic
because
if you haven't experienced growing
pains, it hurts those Charlie horses.
And I'm so thankful that he has not had
to experience those. Um, and another
thing my other kids if I would have
offered and this because they didn't
have the longevity nutrition on board or
even you know beyond what I knew to be
good healthy cooking is if you put
sweets in front of them they were gone.
Alex, he can say no. He just goes right
past. It doesn't it doesn't phase him.
Um, occasionally yes.
It's mom's fault that he gets a sweet
putt in front of him and he will eat it.
But for the most part, he makes such
better choices when it comes to the food
and choosing, especially when we're out
and having to eat. So, he's actually 5'
11 and 3/4. We measured him two days
ago. And um at 14, he is as tall as his
next brother up who's 12 years older
than him. He still has about an inch to
beat his tallest brother, but uh he
definitely will be taller than all of
them. And thank you so much, Alex, for
coming on with me today.
>> You're welcome, mother.
>> You can go now. Um but I just want to
let him go ahead and uh move on out.
>> Let's go to AJ. I saw you unmuted. Did
you want to add something?
>> No. Good kid. Nothing nothing to add.
Nothing to add.
>> All right. Well, um, thank you, Alex.
Let's go over to our next guest that we
have on with us. And I am just, this
lady is just such an inspiration.
Um, somebody that I met,
oh goodness,
physically met you in Cabo San Lucas
just weeks before the COVID shutdown
and you have just been such a delight
and I'm so thankful that you're part of
our Youngevity family and coming on
today talking about your own kiddos.
So, please share share Susan about your
sons and what you have experienced as
well.
>> Thank you. Thanks so much for having me
on. I really appreciate that. It's it's
really an honor to share. Um so, um we
got involved in Younge Jevity about 14
years ago or so. And um my boys, my
youngest was like in eighth grade, so
13ish, 12, 13ish or something like that.
And then my other boys were in in high
school, sophomore, senior I believe. But
um one thing that I we had them attend a
live lecture with Dr. Wallik and um
because I really felt that information
was so important for them. I felt that
that would help them really buy in, you
know, get a really commitment into the
the the program. But we got them on like
the healthy start pack and and um it
made such a difference. Um so
my my two older boys um actually we had
suffered a severe downturn in the
economy you know major that major
collapse of the economy and so we were
really struggling. So my two older boys
got jobs and now my older boys are very
strong academically, very very bright,
very driven in that respect, but they
were so committed to the supplements
that they bought them themselves. you
know, they bought they ordered they they
my my middle son, Daniel, I don't know
if Dage is going to show any of the
pictures, but um um actually signed up
to be a distributor and he, you know, he
talked to all his buddies or whatever
and got them signed up and whatever. And
then, you know, of course, and he's
still a distributor. He's what, how old
is he now? Let me think. Uh 31. Yeah,
31. He's not really actively involved as
much in the business right now, but he's
still making commission on people that
he had signed up when he was still in
high school. Um, but um, so they had a
buyin. That's okay. That's my little my
three boys when they were younger. My
youngest in the front, obviously, he's
the he's the baby. So all my boys are
very tall. Uh, my my oldest and my
youngest are that's my youngest, Ben. So
he's that's when he gosh how old was he
then? Yeah that was I don't know maybe
he was 14ish or something I guess maybe
but um he's 67 and my oldest son is 67
and then my my runt comes in at 64. Okay
so that that next picture is Ben and
Daniel. So um that's when we were
dropping Daniel off at college his
freshman year. Um but um so Ben is the
one that was on the supplements, you
know, we started him the earliest,
right? And to just elaborate a little
bit about him is so my two older boys
were all of them were athletic, which
you know this is great in Indiana and
especially basketball and all the sports
that were part of the school system
there. Um, but um, Ben was more athletic
and he he he was a little bit more if if
you've had children, some require a
little bit more proddding academically,
right? You know, a little more followup,
you know, get your homework done. My two
older ones, I didn't have to, but then I
had to. He had some dyslexia issues. And
um, so the other thing too that we were
he was really experiencing is severe
migraines. And um I mean he was like an
eighth grade and I'd have to go and pick
him up at school or pick him up from
practice and it was just heartbreaking,
you know, because what I didn't know
what to do and and you know he'd be in
in his bedroom. I'd have everything, you
know, all the lights, you know, off and
everything. And he'd be pounding on the
wall. He was in such utter pain. And um
it it was really about that same time
that we got, you know, on Dr. Wallik
supplements. So, I got him on the
healthy start pack um the selenium and I
don't know that I had added the glucco
gel then but um but anyway he he got rid
of his migraines and he has never had
migraines any ever since then. So that
was like oh I was think there he is
right there playing basketball now. Um,
so one of the things I had mentioned to
AJ when I talked to him maybe a month or
so ago that I was very proactive. Um,
and like Braille, you know, she talked
about how important selenium was. That
was something that really, really
touched me to know because, you know, I
see all these young boys running up and
down the court and I did not want, you
know, that to happen, you know, any kind
of cardiomyopathy issue with with them.
And so for sure I felt such a sense of
peace knowing that this kid's protected.
You know, he's got the 90. But the other
thing that I did because I wanted to
prevent injury um I mean was um was such
a you know obvious football but it's
pretty aggressive this in basketball
especially Indiana basketball. Uh very
very competitive and um so he's a he was
a forward there. Um, I got I did
therapeutic dosing of glucco gel. I So I
gave him eight capsules of glucco gel at
breakfast and eight capsules of glucco
gel at dinner because I wanted to have
make sure that he, you know, could
prevent injuries. So it was amazing,
too. He turned his ankle a couple of
times through his varsity basketball or
all of his basketball and um but that
was it and he bounced back really fast.
So, I really felt good about that, you
know, and he's still he's 29 now and he
still takes all the supplements. That
was I don't know if I saw that picture
there, but he takes all the supplements
today. And um and the other thing too is
he um actually now is um licensed
plumber and uh on he's on a big job site
um and he's turning a lot of his fellow
um plumbers onto Rise and Restore. So
I've got some Rise and Restore customers
from him. He's all big on promoting
that. Uh that is um a picture. My boys,
my Ben's on my well on your left to my
right. Uh that's we attended he because
he went into the Marines. So um he um he
got some uh um looks and offers for
basketball, college, basketball, but he
wanted to go into the Marines. So he
went into Marines. So we were there in
San Diego uh at at graduation. We were
at that Airbnb that we had was so
awesome. Um but um anyway um the the
other thing with um with Ben I took some
notes because I want to make sure I
didn't forget anything I about the
dyslexia issue. So we had some issues
with that but when I got him on the
supplements it made such a difference.
you know, I'm not saying that I he
didn't require a little more proddding
academically,
but he didn't require as much and uh
which which is great, you know, and um
and then my other two boys, uh they
were, you know, they were all athletic,
too, but um they were a little more
academically driven and um I mean, you
know, nutrients help your brain, right?
So, so they both got full ride
scholarships to college. Um and um which
is you know I'm so proud of you know
that they were you know got that. So
anyway, um the other thing is um oh um
the um
one of the pictures that's coming up is
my son Matt which is two there's been
hairs there's been a little little hot
dog there lifting weights when he was in
the Marines showing off his bod that's
my family there that we were at some
thing for college my oldest son on the
far right he was some induction thing
that he got so So, and Ben, you can see
you can see how tall they are. If
anybody knows me, I mean, I'm no shrimp.
I'm about 5'6 and a half, but you can
see there's I don't know. It's just
something that I It's so funny when you
hug them, it's like, oh my gosh, I feel
like I'm a little, you know, shrimpy
here, you know. Uh, but um but you know,
I know that really helped them. The
other thing, you know, uh Jill was
talking Oh, you know, you were talking
about that Becca that um the the grow
growing pains. Well, one of the things
that two of the older boys got or um was
that augut slaughters, you know, have
you heard of that ashot slaughters where
you have that knee thing in the you
know, it's really a bone and joint
issue, right? And so they have to wear
this little band protection around their
below their knee to prevent that
whatever that uh tendon or whatever that
is that would pop out. Well, um so I you
know I didn't know about you know I just
thought it was sort of an inevitable
thing. I didn't know. But then Ben never
developed that at all. And of course he
was my most athletic. So I was really
happy that protected that from
developing. It's just it's not an
inevitable thing. It's a deficiency
issue and you you know you just got to
uh uh take the supplements to help that
maintain its elasticity and keep it in
place. Um
>> so um the other thing with my oldest son
Matt, he and his fiance at the time
they're married now. You'll see there.
There they are. There. as Matt and
Destiny. And uh they have two two kids
now. You'll see one of my little
granddaughters in maybe one of the other
pictures. But they after college they
did a 2year um stint in Guinea, Africa
um um in the Peace Corps. There they are
there. That's that they're in their in
their native dress of in Guinea. And the
this the so that Destiny's in the middle
obviously and then to her right my the
left of the picture is my middle son
Daniel. he went to visit them. Um, and
then of course my son to the right of
Destiny, his wife, um, that's Matt. So,
one thing they were in a very, when I
say hostile environment, I mean, it was
tribal. Um, and I was very concerned
about, you know, their health and ex
they're so exposed to so many things,
you know. Uh, first of all, they did a
lot of open air cooking, so there was a
lot of smoke. Um, and then there was,
you know, the the intense heat of the
summer. They they had they lived in a
hut for two years. Um, so when I talked
with them, I was said, "Well, okay, we
what kind of we got to figure out some
sort of a supplementation that's doable,
right? I mean, no air conditioning, no
running water." Um, I mean, it was very
primitive when you when you think of
classic Peacecore. Now granted there's a
lot of I don't know what they call it
puff powder puff peacecore you know but
this was true peacecore um so what we
decided that we would uh send them and
ship as because it was two years the
healthy body start pack on the go uh
because that would be doable for them
and then I think I also did the uh
nature's pearls because I wanted them to
get a lot of antioxidants so I don't
know if anybody's ever shipped things to
Africa you're paying way more in
shipping than you are in actually what
you're putting in the box. But it was
worth it to to us and me to know that
they were getting some of something
nutrition, you know, to help in that
kind of hostile environment that they
were living in for that that two-year
period of time. Now, this is my son,
Daniel, and he's the one that signed up
as a distributor,
and um you know, like I said, he still
has his distributorship and still makes
an income. And that's his wife there.
He's my he's my run at 6'4. Uh but he's
extremely, you know, bright and healthy
and he does um I trying to remember what
happened. He does have some kind of a
hip issue that he deals with. So he's
make sure he stays, you know, on the
supplements with the glucco gel and that
really helps counteract some is there.
There they are right there. Some wedding
I think they tuned in Florida. So um and
they're on the supplements and they
haven't they don't have any babies yet.
So, we're making sure that she's um you
know, getting all the nutrients she
needs to have really healthy babies.
We're all about healthy babies.
Okay. And that's now that's Ben. That's
my baby that has been on and I would say
he's the most committed more than anyone
on the supplementations.
Um and that's that's his little niece,
our little one of our little
granddaughters. and um um and he you
know, like I said, he's pitching it with
his plumber friends and they're all
getting the Rise and Restore, but I
think the the big thing was making sure
they understood why, you know, and and
here's the thing, too, and you know, in
doing consultations with people and
parents and whatever, you know, I just
say, well, you know, we just didn't give
our kids an option. You know, we didn't,
oh, mommy, I don't like that or, you
know, or whatever. I mean, granted, we'd
work with them to, but they never they
they they they were bought in because
they heard the message. They understood
the aspect of deficiencies and things
like that. And I really think that
really made a difference in them being I
don't know what I don't I hate you word
the word use the word compliant, but in
a way it was because well, we would give
them their supplements. We we'd put them
together, right? I didn't, you know,
when they were younger and then so they
developed a habit and then uh but then
the food thing uh was it Jill that
mentioned that um or or maybe you Becca
did. Yes. So you know we've been
following Dr. Walk's good food bad food
diet for over gosh 13 years pretty much
since we started almost and that's been
really a um a big benefit because all my
boys are foodies in the sense that they
are not junk food eaters at all. And
now, um, Dan, my Daniel is 100%
gluten-free. Ben is for the most part.
Matthew, not so much. But, but they're
all they're all definitely about eating
healthy. They're not, you know, going
out and eating junk food and all that
stuff. So, that that was a big um mile
set for them when in the family
influence and things like that. So
anyway, I I just I feel so thankful um
that Dr. Wallik's message and that you
know you know I we found him as a family
and um it's been quite um just a
wonderful experience.
Oh, I think that's fantastic. And I
think we as parents
need to be more of the authority when it
comes to what goes in their body
>> because I know a lot of times,
especially with Alex, he had texture
issues and it did take a little bit of
trying to, you know, figure out, okay,
how is he going to drink this tanky
tangerine? Because we know that is
what's going to be the most absorbable.
Mhm.
>> Um but for him we added in soul from the
longevity line where Jill had mentioned
the electrofuel
soul is right there with next to the
electrofuel and it made the taste where
he actually enjoys it now. So when he's
with me, he drinks his tangy tangerine,
his osteo effects and soul. When he's
with his dad, like you mentioned, the
onthe-go packs
and it's the matter of getting the
nutrition in their bodies.
>> Right. For sure.
>> So
you've been in this seven years longer
than I have.
You've brought your kids up using the
Youngevity products.
I wish that I had the Youngevity
products whenever my older kids were
younger because we also dealt with some
dyslexia.
Um, and then
the the the d-stress, oh my goodness,
has been just a great great addition for
those kiddos that have issues with
attention deficit or deficiencies
or anxiety, inability to really cope
with stress. Those vitamins have been
fantastic, not just for
con uh con uh heart failure. Congestive
heart failure, that's the word I'm
looking for.
>> So, what else do you think um from what
you know now and working with clients?
What are some other recommendations that
you have
as far as well, let's say for protocols?
I mean, um
I mean I like I as far as like getting
the 90 and in and a very easy because
sometimes you got to find what's going
to be the most convenient what they're
going to take.
>> I'll usually do like the ultimate uh
tangy tangerine, the liquid and the
smart FX that's that gets you all the
90. You still get 300 milligrams of your
calcium. Um, and that that has been a a
protocol that a lot of my clients kids
seem to do really well on. First of all,
the Smart FX has a very high amount of
DHA, you know, which is just brain food,
right? And they're very very small and
and they're very that makes them very
easy to swallow. Um, especially for
younger kids, but even, you know,
teenagers sometimes kind of are, you
know, abrasive with swallowing stuff
like that. Um but um but again, you
know, it's like the parent like you
said, you you really do have to,
you know, be the authority figure and
and and not just acquies to what you
know, I don't want to, you know, or they
get fussy. But but that's where the
buyin comes in if they understand why.
And especially kids that are involved in
athletics, you know, there's so much
information out there and they
understand, you know, even with all the
famous athletes, you they know that they
neutrify. They know they're doing
something, right? But um I used to
manage GNC's back in the day. And um but
most of the things that they used would
be like just protein shakes or
preworkouts or creatine or something
which are fine. these are okay, but it's
not the micronutrients and those
foundational things. So, there is some
education as it relates to that, but
appeal to the kids that are athletic.
Hey, this will help you in your
performance. This will help you prevent
injury, you know, um these kinds of
things. But but the other thing too is,
you know, we we set stuff up. We we
modeled that. We did, you know, we we
took it ourselves. So he modeled that,
you know, we just we just say, you know,
uh do you do not what I tell you to do,
but do follow my example. And following
that example, I think that's been
important, too, in that respect.
>> Oh, I totally agree. That's that's one
thing I was going to say. We've got to
set the example
>> example, right,
>> for our children. And I absolutely agree
with you when it comes to
giving them information because I'm not
a oh just do what I say type of person.
>> But it's about educating them so that
they know why
it is that we are just so
adamant
>> Yeah.
>> about making sure that our kids are
getting the nutrition they need. Well,
and even, you know, like my son, my
youngest one, he was just what, what, 12
or 13. I mean, he wasn't too young. I
mean, I mean, even 8 10 year olds,
they're not too young to to understand
this information and and um, you know,
grasps the importance and significance
of supplementation, you know. Um,
>> so, you know, that just having them that
buy in really helps them you know, have
some skin in the game, so to speak.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. And Jill had
mentioned that um her son just started
on the soul and which was it? Um smart
also convenient little pouches. You just
add it to water, dissolves instantly to
help with focus in school and combat
stress. So, two more great products that
Young has added to their lineup of
products to help us help our families to
thrive even more. Now, we have a
question coming in and you can help me
answer this.
>> Okay.
>> Ann is wanting to know, "What do you
recommend for a baby?" Her first
grandchild is due in August.
Congratulations, Ann. Being a grandma
nana is a great place to be. We welcome
you to that club.
What would you recommend, Susan?
>> Uh, great question. Um, first of all, I
guess the biggest question is, um, is
the mother nursing?
>> If the mother's nursing,
>> the best question. If the mother's
nursing, then you don't and she she
needs to be on the supplements
and then you wouldn't really need to
provide any additional nutrition for
that little infant as long as the mother
is taking supplements. Um, now once the
child is weaned or begins eating, you
know, drinking,
you know, and I when I say weaned, I
don't even mean 100% weaned because, you
know, you can nurse. I mean, I don't
know. I think my daughter-in-law's and
she's busy going to school and all this
stuff. She's still busy, but she's still
nursing even at two years. Um, granted,
it's reduced amount. But, um, so let's
say you begin to introduce food, solid
foods, seven months maybe, right? Uh,
first of all, you got to have the
parents buy in. I mean, there's no,
that's just it, you know? But, um, one
of the liquids would be good. Uh, I know
there's a um a kids totty. Um, I've
never tasted that before. It's not
terribly high in a lot of nutrients, but
it's for this the size of an infant,
that could be a good place to introduce
it into, I don't know, water or some
type of a drink or something. And based
on the child's weight, I mean, you may
not even use a whole ounce. Maybe just
use a half an ounce. Now,
>> teaspoon even. Yeah, you have a
teaspoon. And then the other thing too
is I mean essential fatty acids are
really important. Um, so I would say
even the smart FX, you know, just even
one of those and you can prick it and
squeeze it on something would be good.
That's going to pretty much get you all
the 90. Now, you could introduce some of
the minerals, too, cuz I don't think the
I don't think the kids taughty has trace
minerals in there. But even, you know, a
teaspoon of the plant minerals in
something or like um what was it that
Jill did? The cherry men's or something
like that or just the plains. You don't
need that much. So, you could put it in
some other form of liquid and uh have
them drink that. But if the mother's
nursing, you wouldn't need anything as
long as that she's supplementing
herself. Do you know if the mother is
going is going to be supplementing while
she's
>> um we do not know. So Ann, first thing
get mama on the nutrients and have her
stay on them, especially if she is is
nursing.
>> Um and you know, you had mentioned the
plant derived minerals. Jill had shown a
picture of her husband Rob and Ian
holding up the cherry men's. You know,
putting that in your water,
>> that's going to be some amazing
electrolyte fil water,
>> which
and it tastes good.
>> Yeah.
>> So, cherry men, strawberry, kiwi mints,
whichever one you want to do. Well, and
as they get a little bit older, you
know, as they get a little older, you
could do um what were the little what
are they called?
>> Oh, I forgot what
>> the kids sprinkles.
>> The kids sprinkles. Now, there, you
know, it's not exhaustive. It's not
like, you know, when you look at the
supplement facts, it's, you know, you
would still want to do some minerals and
some EFAs or something like that. But
the other thing is, you know, when you
start the kids young, um, they, you
know, their taste buds are developed in
such a way that it's not going to be a
problem. You're not going to run into a
big fight or something like that as they
maybe they get older and they don't like
the stuff or something. But
>> yeah.
>> Well, awesome. And of course,
yes.
I, you know, I love the fact that we're
in a live situation where people are
able to ask questions. People
more than just AJ. AJ.
>> Hey, Susan. Thank you so very much for
being on with us. I really uh love
hearing your story and seeing how
healthy and happy your your kids have
grown. Um but you said that your short
child, the 6'4 guy,
>> he he he started his own YGY business.
What age was that?
>> He was a sophomore in high school
>> and it was 16.
um uh 15 16. Yeah, around that age,
right? And it was so fun because he, you
know, he got dressed up in his like nice
jacket and suit and had me take a
picture of him because, you know, to
promote I don't know how do I guess he
had Oh, yeah. Cuz to put his picture on
his longevity distributor account,
right? And um and you know, he had he
had the CDs and he and he's of course,
you know, now you got links and stuff,
but back then it was CDs. So, he
listened to Dead Doctors Don't Lie
Again. He listened to, you know, all the
ones, you know, like serial killers and
all the ones that were really, you know,
all that were so great for information.
He he was hungry and which was exciting.
And he still is very, you know, very
health consscious and takes supplements
today as well.
>> So you're saying at And how old is he
now?
>> He is um 31.
>> So he So he's had an account for 15
years.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
Well, almost as long as I have.
>> And you're saying this 15year-old kid
started a business that he's still
getting a check from today.
>> Yes, he still gets commission. Now, he's
not actively building like he had been
because, you know, he's is he doing some
other jobs working and stuff like that.
Um, but he's still I mean, all the work
that he put into it in the past, he's
still reaping benefits from it.
>> Did he ever reach one star?
>> No. No, he never reached one star. He
didn't reach one star.
>> No, I mean he he se well our regional
RMD whatever they call those back then.
So it would have been
>> um senior
senior associate. He definitely was
senior associate.
>> Wow. That is impressive.
That that's inspiration.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. I'm pretty pretty proud of
those boys for sure.
>> No, that 31. Yeah, Daniel's No, Daniel's
30. I don't know. Well, anyway, they're
all close, you know. So,
but you like you if you know I surely
wish I had known about this when I was
pregnant or before I had babies, you
know, and of course I didn't, right?
Because it I don't know when was Dr.
Wall started. I could have known I
suppose because my oldest was born in
1993. When did start lecturing? Was that
96? Um well, you know what? This year's
30 years.
>> 30 years. So
>> that longevity has been longevity.
>> Well, that just makes you feel so much
more conf confident in a company that's
have been that enduring, doesn't it?
>> Yeah. Through through so many different
things,
>> they just continue to get stronger and
stronger. I love that.
Well, thank you so much, Susan. Greatly
appreciate having me.
>> I feel honored. I feel very honored to
be asked.
>> Well, thank you. Thank you.
>> We We appreciate you. All that you do,
all that you help us do and contributing
to um you know, so many people out there
that
don't know how important
>> nutrition is. So, thank you. I
appreciate you. Thank you, Jill and Alex
for coming on shortly. And so, there's a
couple things that I wanted to mention
before we get to our final pictures
as we are putting together our medicine
cabinet for our kids,
okay? especially if you're just getting
started and we want to do things a
little more natural
when we've got our kiddos on a strong
nutritional program.
And this is something that I noticed. I
think Alex has had a fever maybe once in
his life. He has been on the Youngevity
products for almost 10 years now.
You don't they just don't get
they they don't catch everything that
comes along,
>> right?
>> You know, so making sure that you have
the colloidal silver because yeah, they
are going to fall. They're going to get
scrapes. They're going to get bumped.
>> You got the colloidal silver. You can
put in a spray bottle, spray it, you can
put it in their mouth. There is
absolutely no flavor to it. Um, we've
even used it for other kids that have
had um,
>> sty
>> get some type of eye infection,
>> right?
>> What? AJ,
>> you can't say the CS word on YouTube.
>> CS.
Oh, sorry. You know, there's so many
things that
the F or different platforms just don't
want us to say. They don't want you to
know the truth. But I'm sorry, AJ. Um,
so in your kids, in your kids medicine
cabinet, let's go ahead and get those
kids sprinkles in there. Especially if
your kiddles are four years old and
older, you just sprinkle them on the
tongue. They dissolve instantly. When
they get to about oh, seven, eight years
old and and even before, you can start
off with the kids totty. When they get
to seven, eight years old and they're
reaching close to 75 pounds, you can
even go right into the tangy tangerine
osteo FX and the EFAs. Yes, smart FX.
That's S period, M period, A period, R
period, T period, FX, it is an acronym,
are small. They're easy to swallow. They
could even chew them up and then swallow
them. And same with the EFAs. EFA+.
Those are brain food, folks. They're
also nature's blood cleaner. So, we want
to make sure that we are keeping the
blood clean, keeping our kids nutriated.
Um, another thing to get into that kid's
cabinet is the root beer belly. As Shel
had mentioned, even for babies, if they
get collicky and have a tummy ache, you
and they especially if they have a
pacifier, just moisten the little tip of
the pacifier, dip it in the powder,
they'll suck it. It gets down into the
digestive system. That gives them
probiotics
and enzymes that help with digestion.
And that's the big thing about the root
beer belly. It's a great way to get
probiotics and some enzymes into your
kiddos to help make sure that they have
a microbiome that is functioning.
Another great thing is the I26. Those
chewables taste great. If your kids love
vanilla, you got the vanilla. If they
like more or lean more towards coconut
and banana, you got coconut and banana.
and they don't like flavors,
do the powder, mix it up into something
and hide it. It tastes, for me, it just
tastes like the shell of like an eclair.
There's no no real flavor to it. A
couple more things that you can add to
that, especially if you deal with kids
that seem to get um sick often.
You've got the good herbs line. You've
got the immune support. You've got the
super olive health, the respiratory and
sinus pro um respiratory,
their circulation, there's the sinus
allergy. Those are tinctures and also
bone and joint which helps to support
the the connective tissue and the bones
of the body. It just takes one dropper
full which is about half a teaspoon. You
can put it in a little bit of water. If
you want to set it out the night before,
that's okay. They can drink it and be
done with it. And that just helps gives
us one more tool in our toolbox to help
us help our kids. Now, AJ, I think
you've got a couple more pictures to
show that I am
um very tickled
that
our CEO
has shared and COO,
so our chief executive oper um
yeah and our COO officer um have shared
And these are Dr. Wallik's or two of Dr.
Wallik's grandchildren.
Um, we have the oldest one and the
youngest one
as they are showing you. First was Ruper
Belly. Now, this is the youngest one
showing the kids totty. This is Andrew,
um, who is now in college and going to
be a veterinarian just like his
grandfather, which I'm super super
tickled to see. Here we're doing the one
of our shakes, our strawberry shake that
we used to have um from the keto line.
Another one that tastes great. Now we
have the TMR both in chocolate and
vanilla. Meal replacements. So, K, if
your kids need more nutrition, got meal
replacements to help get that in. That
tastes great. What else do you have, AJ?
Oh, there we go. And two thumbs up.
What is that?
>> Not sure, but they're happy.
>> Oh, oh, oh, oh. I think that's the kids
totty that they are that they are
showing there. Um, and that they take.
And of course behind them is a whole
counter full of longevity products,
which
is not hard to do. When you find
something that you totally believe in,
you always have something to turn to.
And one more picture.
>> Yeah, that was the last one. We saw this
one with the kid, the root beer belly.
>> All right. Well, folks, thank you so
much for joining us here on Daily with
Doc. My name is Becca Dukes, and if I
could get my co-hosts up on the screen
with me, you know, and Susan, come on
back. Jill, if you're here, come on up.
Um, you know, this is a family. We're a
family business. We care about families,
and we want to make sure that families
are uh as healthy as they absolutely can
be. And one way to help do that, there's
no guarantees. People are still going to
make their own choices, but is to make
sure that they have the nutrition
available. And as parents,
let's make sure that we get the
nutrition into our children by setting
an example and having it having them do
it right along with us. Now, uh Susan,
there is one question coming in. How
tall is your husband? because the kids
are taller towering over him even.
>> I know. I know. He's 6'1.
>> Uh 61
on both sides of our family. My
greatgrandfather,
this is way back, right? He was 65
and that was like way back in the day,
right? And then um
>> Awesome.
>> Yeah. So, there's a lot of height on
both sides of our family, but
>> Very cool. Awesome. Great question. And
a couple more things to add to that
medicine cabinet. We've got the apple
cider vinegar gummies. Also very helpful
for digestion. Thank you, Jill, for
mentioning that. Um, for our kids that
are active, you want to make sure that
you have that CM cream. That's going to
help whenever they do overexert
themselves. You've got something to help
ease some of the the pain there. and
also physical care which is an essential
oil blend that you can mix into that ZM
cream for additional support. Uh
especially for our children that are
very active and start getting those
stinky feet. Make sure that you get that
tea tree essential oil. You can mix that
into plant derived minerals. Shake it
up, put it in a spray bottle, and have
your own foot spray to help uh get over
the athletes foot.
>> You can do same thing with lavender and
help with sunburn. The lavender and the
plant derived minerals and uh plant
derived minerals is amazing for sunburn.
>> Yes, it is. Oh, absolutely. And then
also the to be well essential oil also
um which helps to build immune system.
So folks you know there is so much that
we can do and it's just about having
knowledge and sharing that knowledge
with each and every one of you that is
at our heart's desire. So I want to do a
shout out and thank you to all of my
co-hosts and my guests today. We've got
Albert letting people in. Thank you,
Albert, joining us at 11 p.m. in the
middle of the night. We have Susan
joining us as a guest. Thank you so
much, Susan. We have Marilyn who is
typing her little fingers away. So, if
you're here live with us and you've got
that chat open, you know how busy she's
working. We have Sherry who's part of
our tech team helping to get the stream
going and keeping an eye on things to
make sure everything is still streaming
with sound. Thank you so much, Sherry.
Uh Jill joining us on the road. Thank
you, Jill. As a guest, we have Ruth
Ellen, my executive production manager,
helping to keep everybody in line. And
also the stream, if you're watching us
out on any of the different platforms,
it's because of Ruth Ellen taking this
program, adding the graphics to it, and
pushing it out to the stream and AJ for
helping us get our guests together today
as I was on vacation and also getting us
out on all those different platforms. So
folks, get back with the person that
shared this program with you. tell them
thank you and say hey I want to get my
kids what they need to be proactive
especially proactive because you know
being pro proactive is so much more
affordable than being reactive when they
get sick.
So there is something that we can do
that helps us to limit or avoid so many
of those deficiency type symptoms and
conditions as Dr. Wallik found that
there are 90 essential nutrients
and on average about 10 poor health
symptoms associated with with each one.
So, you do 90 times.
>> We're wrapping the show. One second.
>> And AJ is trying to uh close us out. So,
folks, thank you so much for joining us
here on dailywithdoc.com.
Go ahead and go to dailywithdoc.com.
Make sure you sign up for the
newsletter. If you were not referred to
this show by somebody and you're not
working with anybody,
we do have a store on our website. If
you want to get with a certified
holistic health coach and you're not
working with anybody, you weren't
referred to any this show by anybody, I
do have a team of certified holistic
health coaches on our call team at
855-9493377.
Again, that's 855-9493377.
So folks, thank you so much for joining
us. Have a fantastic day. We will see
you tomorrow with pharmacist Ben. And
what AJ, you've got your hand up again.
>> Well, because somebody cuz Olga
mentioned that she wanted to see the
cutest uh guest on the show again.
Who?
>> Like I mean how how cute?
>> Just
>> Oh yes, she is the cutest. Isn't she
>> so adorable?
Awesome. Well, thank you so much, Olga.
And thank you everybody for investing a
little bit of time into yourself. And
also, I want to do a special shout out
for one of our amazing coaches, Key, who
is helping me put things together in the
background. So, thank you so much, Key,
for for your private messages to me as
well. So, everybody have a great day and
until next time, don't forget,
you are important, your families are
important, and you're worth investing
the best nutrition into each and every
one of you.
Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Thank you.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.